desde principios de octubre todos los
hospitales de la región de parís pasaron
al modo de emergencia los contagiados
con coronavirus constituyen casi la
mitad de todos los pacientes en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos pero
preocupa la llegada en simultáneo de
pacientes con otras dolencias
ya sabemos que estamos abrumados en
realidad todas las camas están ocupadas
el 50% por pacientes con kobe 19 y el
otro 50% para los demás pacientes
desafortunadamente cuando el clima se
pone frío se espera un aumento
significativo del número de pacientes
5.019 que vienen por diferentes
problemas como enfermedades crónicas
y fallas cardíacas o respiratorias
enfermedades estacionales virales y
gripe
al interior de los hospitales el
ambiente empieza a volverse tenso los
trabajadores de la salud deben
enfrentarse de nuevo a una situación muy
difícil como lo fue en los primeros
meses tras la llegada de la pandemia a
europa es preocupante pero al mismo
tiempo es lo que esperábamos vemos que
las cifras están aumentando pero
afortunadamente el número de muertes aún
no está aumentando según las autoridades
sanitarias francesas la cantidad de
pruebas positivas de coi 19 se ha
duplicado en las últimas semanas
especialmente en personas jóvenes creo
que para nosotros como generación de
veinteañeros vamos a pagar caro los
próximos 10 años
pagaremos por este confinamiento parís y
otras 8 ciudades han implementado un
'toque de queda' de nueve de la noche a
seis de la mañana en un intento por
frenar los contagios una medida que
pronto podría ser adoptada en otras
regiones del país que entrarían a su vez
en alerta roja incluso el gobierno ha
propuesto de extender el estado de
emergencia hasta el próximo 16 de
febrero